i escaped california in 2020
and frankly i feel like i was a couple
of years too late i've been discussing
with my wife the possibility of leaving
california for a while i've been
discussing with my business partner
jeremy boring the possibility of taking
our company and moving it out of state
for quite a while but finally we pulled
the trigger in 2020 and not a moment too
soon as it turns out because california
has now reduced itself to a smoldering
ash heap apparently it is amazing how
governance makes a difference it really
does because california has been blessed
with some of the greatest assets that
god has ever bestowed upon mankind it's
got beautiful natural scenery it's got
unbelievable natural resources it has
high levels of intellectual capital it's
a huge bustling population and yet
somehow they are turning california into
a dystopian hellscape it truly is an
unbelievable thing
and the vision for california has
changed and if california is sort of the
harbinger of the future from the left
then it behooves us to take a look at
what california has become
the california dream
used to be that you would come out to
california you get a job maybe working
at jpl or maybe working in hollywood and
then you'd be able to afford a house in
burbank or a house in the san fernando
valley amidst the orange groves
with the white picket fence and two and
a half kids and you'd be able to create
a life for yourself this was the promise
of california and if you look back at
the old tourism videos from the 1950s in
california this was the pitch everything
was clean and new
okay now obviously this is not to
pretend that there were no problems in
california or in the country in 1953 the
most obvious being segregation although
in california segregation was lower than
it was in most other places in the
country l.a was one of the least
segregated cities in america in the
1950s but
to pretend that racism wasn't a massive
problem in the 1950s is of course silly
but that's not the point the point is
that the vision that was being presented
for what life would be like in a
thriving california was pretty simple it
was law abiding you had shows on tv
in the 50s and 60s about the greatness
of the lapd you had a generalized
feeling of opportunity this is a great
place to raise a family
here's a tourism video from 1953 sort of
bragging about what's best in california
in the years since the turn of the
century los angeles has grown from a
sleepy pueblo to a vast seething
metropolitan city
fine buildings huge stores busy citizens
this is hollywood boulevard and the
world-renowned grauman's chinese theater
in the forecourt of this celebrated
cinema house are the footprints of the
outstanding stars of the screen it is
almost unnecessary to say that among the
chief attractions of the southern
california picture is its many miles of
beaches where you can be as athletic as
you choose or just love around and build
up a beautiful tan
okay so um if you went back to
california right now and you went to
each one of those sites they're hell
holes they really are i mean that video
opens driving through downtown los
angeles or you can see city hall in that
in that particular video and city hall
is now slum row
it it is a it is a homeless encampment
and then they show grauman's chinese
right right on on hollywood boulevard
and they're close to sunset and vine
over there and that's kind of the center
of hollywood that place has been taken
over by the homeless a couple of years
ago there was a person who literally had
a bucket of feces thrown on her at the
intersection that they show in that
video and then they show santa monica
beach which used to be clean and nice
santa monica beach is so bad that the
weekend before my family left california
and we were getting kind of nostalgic
because my wife and i had gone on our
first date
at the coffee bean near santa monica
beach and then we had gone for a walk
along the beach and even then it wasn't
so bad this is 2008
2007 late 2007. and um and we went back
there as sort of a sort of a nostalgia
play we brought our kids to a park on
santa monica beach where a homeless man
was trying to expose himself to people
another homeless man was spitting at
patrons of a restaurant and open needles
were visible everywhere
they have wrecked california they've
completely wrecked it and they seem to
be
morally invested in wrecking california
they seem to feel good about wrecking
california
it's as though they've decided that all
of the benefits of living in california
have to go away and the way that they're
going to make up for the for the
complete failure of their system of
thought
is by proclaiming their own moral
superiority so the latest
the latest round of this sort of
insanity comes courtesy of the
associated press
it's an amazing amazing story it really
says all that you need to know about
what california is and where california
is going
apparently california is seeking to
become now what they call an abortion
sanctuary so first of all i just want to
point out the the linguistic insanity of
that phrase
the word sanctuary comes from the
same root as the word sanctified
right a sanctuary is a place that is
sanctified that is what a sanctuary is
and
in the in the before times and when when
there were ecclesiastical courts
throughout europe
you were able to rush to a church if you
wish to avoid criminal culpability
people would rush to churches
for sanctuary right they would claim
sanctuary this is obviously a major plot
point in for example the administrator
cube goes hunchback of notre dame
is people rushing into is esmeralda
rushing into the cathedral of notre dame
and claiming sanctuary saying that she
wishes to be subject to ecclesiastical
law as opposed to the the king's law
sanctuary was a way of claiming god's
providence over you and not the state's
providence
now you have the state of california
declaring sanctuary
for either illegal activity in the form
of illegal immigration or for
the worst sin in american life abortion
it's now going to be a sanctuary a
sanctified place protected from all
others
for abortion
you're not rushing to avoid culpability
for a for an act for which you believe
you are innocent
you instead are rushing to a sanctified
place where your abortion can be
protected the the language is is so
paganistic as to shock the conscience
according to the associated press with
more than two dozen states poised to ban
abortion if the united states supreme
court gives them okay next year
california clinics and their allies in
the state legislature on wednesday
revealed a plan to make the state a
sanctuary for those seeking reproductive
care to euphemism including possibly
paying for travel lodging and procedures
for people from other states
so they're not just saying we're going
to keep abortion legal in california
which is exactly what you would expect
of course they're literally saying that
they will take the taxpayer dollars of
the people who pay taxes in california
to pay women to come to the states to
kill their unborn children so remember
the california dream was come here raise
a family buy a house get a job
lead a law-abiding life and contribute
to the building of the world's greatest
economy
and now the california dream is move to
california get a crappy one-bedroom
studio apartment have a homeless guy
sitting directly outside your door
shooting heroin into his feet
and if you need an abortion we'll pay
your hotel and maybe medical bills the
california dream is come on over here
we'll put you up at the hilton and we'll
carve that baby right out of you
that is a rather astonishing change and
bespeaks a suicidal society any society
that is actively incentivizing abortion
is is a suicidal society there's no
other way to put it you're literally
destroying your fertility rates you're
destroying your future on a literal
level the k if kids are the future as
the left constantly agrees right we all
agree kids are the future because there
literally is no future without kids then
actively fomenting the killing of unborn
children
seems to be anti-future but california
isn't about building a future anymore
california is about a vision of utopian
society in which full stasis has been
reached
if you found a company in california
right now you're an idiot
i've talked to some of the biggest
industrial founders in california i've
talked to some of the biggest tech
people in california people like with i
i promise you the biggest tech companies
in california and they've told me
personally if they were founding their
companies today there is no way in hell
they would put those companies in
california there's a reason that elon
musk just moved tesla's headquarters out
of california
there's a reason for this this is a
dying state and they are choosing the
death this is a suicidal state in terms
of policy
and a morally benefited state of debt
the california future of abortion
council made up of more than 40 abortion
providers and advocacy groups according
to the ap released a list of 45
recommendations for the state to
consider if the high court overturns roe
versus wade the 48 year old decision
that forbids states from outlawing
abortion
the recommendations are not just a
liberal fantasy some of the state's most
important policymakers helped write them
including tony atkins the san diego
democrat who leads the state senate and
attended multiple meetings
democratic governor gavin newsom started
the group himself and in an interview
last week with the ap said some of the
report's details will be included in his
budget proposal in january we will be a
sanctuary newsom said adding he's aware
patients will likely travel to
california from other states to seek
abortions we're looking at ways to
support that inevitability and looking
at ways to expand our protections
california already pays for abortions
for many low-income residents through
the state's medicaid program and
california is one of six states that
require private insurance companies to
cover abortions although many patients
still up end up paying deductibles and
co-payments
but money won't be a problem for state
funded abortion services for patients
from other states california's coffers
have soared throughout the pandemic
fueling a record budget surplus this
year you know why the california coffers
sword because the federal government
pumped so much money into the economy
that california actually increased its
tax take
for all the jabbering about how states
were going to go bankrupt because of
kovid states made money during covet
because the because the federal
government
pumped an unprecedented amount of money
into the economy
and then california just taxed it they
actually had a state surplus last year
next year the state's independent
legislative office predicts california
will have a surplus of about 31 billion
of course none of that takes into
account the structural debts that the
state of california has which probably
run into the hundreds of billions or
trillions at this point
california's abortion providers are
asking the state to make it easier for
people to get to the state the report
recommends funding including public
spending to support patients seeking
abortion for travel expenses like gas
lodging transportation and child care so
some states try to incentivize you to
come to their state by giving you a job
or giving you a child tax credit or
something the state of california is
encouraging people to come to the state
of abortion to the state of abortion
come to the state of california
and be paid to perform abortions uh
full-scale moral insanity
they're asking lawmakers to reimburse
abortion providers for services to those
who can't afford to pay
a huge influx of people from other
states will definitely destabilize the
abortion provider network said fabiola
carrion the interim director for
reproductive and sexual health at the
national health law program she said
out-of-state abortions would also likely
be later term procedures which are more
complicated and more expensive the
report asks lawmakers to help clinics
increase their workforce to prepare for
more patients by giving scholarships to
medical students who pledge to offer
abortion services in rural areas help
them pay off their student loans and
assist with their monthly liability
insurance premiums
so now we are going to pay up-and-coming
medical students to violate hippocratic
oath
amazing amazing stuff and again speaks
to the morality of california where it
is all about a feeling of of consonance
with left-wing morality and not at all
about the quality of life or future of
the state which is why if you are in
california and you do not agree with
this stuff get the hell out now run i've
been telling people this since we left
okay i stuck around for as long as i
thought it was possible to stay around i
do not understand why people are
sticking around in california if they
have a shred of sanity about them at
this point this is not getting better it
is getting worse
there is no point in california where
they are going to turn around and
realize that they've completely botched
this thing beyond all recognition
they're not going to do it there are too
many democrats in the state
california is the most populous
republican state they're the most
republicans in california of any state
because the population of california is
upwards of 40 million
if you are a red state person in the
blue state of california get out while
the getting is good
move to a purple state move to a red
state it'll improve your life radically
and you won't be complicit in the
taxpayer funding of the of the death of
the unborn the fact that this has become
the california dream it's a california
nightmare
unreal and by the way the california
nightmare is on every scale it's on
every scale it makes elites feel really
good about themselves because they they
can say i paid for this poor this poor
woman's abortion i paid for her abortion
that homeless guy he gets to live on the
street because of me
and we even have needle exchanges look
how much sympathy we have for people
we're not prosecuting criminals we want
those criminals to be out on the street
should somebody's life be ruined just
because they engage in a smash and grab
every so often
well i'm glad that they feel good about
themselves because they can afford to to
wall themselves off in their own little
elysium
but that ain't the real world and
california is becoming a hellscape for
the vast majority of its citizens at
this point
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment